hello I'm Robin Thicke and my ultimate
reward is being inspired by the sights
and sounds of the most romantic city in
the world have some of my favorite
things about Paris the beauty the
culture the river the art the museum's
the food probably the food first I get
to the room and I get a French onion
soup and a salad with light vinaigrette
dressing and steak frites that's first
thing I do and then later on his little
caviar and champagne hello how are you
lopressor really is my favorite
restaurant here I was reading a book
recently by Ernest Hemingway and when he
was here he used to eat at the residue
obviously a very historical restaurant
with some of the best food in Paris
Paris is the only city that I don't mind
walking all day long love to walk this
psalm City say all the way from the
Arctic triumph to the Louvre and across
the bridge you don't know what's around
every corner and every nook and cranny
so it's really exciting to be here and
just walk and live and exist but it
seems that in Paris in return you make
there's another great store and every
time I come here I always learn
something about fashion and what's new
what's fresh and what's different I saw
yellow ties with red pocket scarves red
jeans with white jackets this is what
Paris is all about Paris to me sounds
like artistic freedom this is the
capital of taking anything and making it
beautiful I think that that's why
artists flock here whether you're Jim
Morrison or Lenny Kravitz or Picasso we
all have to visit here to show our royal
artistic oats being a soul musician and
making soul music to come here and and
know that this city is probably the most
soulful city in the world it has a heart
it has a pulse it as a soul to it the
just can't match it makes me connect
with something more important on the
inside that I really wanted was put into
my music tell me something sweet tell me
something nice tell me something good
baby tell me it's all right tell me that
your luck tell me you'll be there I'll
get so worried sometimes the world will
not be fair little piece of that okay